je m'appelle sarah mcbride et je
suis une fière transgenre américaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous démontrerons que notre élan est
plus puissant que n'importe quel
président et que tout préjugé que nous
continuerons à faire avancer l'égalité, quels que soient
les défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés  mes premiers souvenirs sont d'être
allongé dans mon lit la nuit en priant pour
que je me réveille le lendemain et que
je sois moi-même que
ma famille serait toujours fière de moi et
que je pouvais encore rêver de grands rêves,
mais à ma première année à l'université,
cette douleur était devenue  trop
ils étaient choqués mais plus que
tout ils avaient peur ils avaient peur
du rejet
ils avaient peur de la discrimination ils
avaient peur de la violence alors qu'en
même temps
malgré leur peur ils comprenaient aussi
que leur rôle de parents
était de m'aimer  et soutenez-moi
[Musique] l'
une des choses qui a été si
importante pour
notre famille tout au long de ce voyage est
que nous avons senti qu'il était important de
partager notre histoire que
nous comprenons  qu'il devient beaucoup plus
difficile de haïr quelqu'un ou de craindre
quelqu'un dont vous connaissez l'histoire
et donc tout au long de ce processus, nous avons
été disposés à partager nos histoires
publiquement
[Musique]
elle s'est courageusement tenue devant l'
assemblée générale
pour décrire ses luttes personnelles avec
l'identité de genre
et  communiquer son désir de rentrer
chez elle
dans le Delaware après avoir obtenu son diplôme
universitaire
sans crainte  vivre ouvertement
et équitablement
[Musique]
Je suis complètement convaincu qu'à travers
tous ces défis, nous
démontrerons ce que nous avons démontré
depuis le mur de pierre jusqu'aux marches de la
Cour suprême,
nous démontrerons que notre élan est
plus puissant que n'importe quel
président et que n'importe quel préjugé qui  nous
continuerons à faire avancer l'égalité, quels que
soient les défis auxquels nous sommes confrontés
et que nous construirons un monde où notre
compréhension de w  e le peuple comprend enfin
chacun d'entre nous